you know that's the scary part is if we
start clicking and keep getting better
um it is going to be
a fun ride we don't want that to be our
our legacy you know that first game and
we don't want that to be the story told
about
the 2020
you know i think played very very well
tonight um
considering we we threw the ball 60
times i heard the rape reviews and uh
could tell it's true that the hype is
real with joe
some of the guys we saw thursday night
as the cleveland browns emerged
victorious 35 to 30 over the cincinnati
bengals it's pro football talk live
peter king joining me today getting you
ready for week two but looking back
at thursday night's
official first thursday night football
game of the year good morning peter how
are you doing
good morning mike everything's going
okay yourself
all good and we keep rolling and it's
funny once football season's back it's
like it never left and that thursday
night game that first short week game
that's to me when it's really on because
that's when the rhythm is starting to
kick in where it's thursday sunday
monday thursday sunday monday and last
night's game a fun one to watch a better
game than i expected it to be and let's
spend some time talking about what the
browns were able to do and for the most
part they they shut up the critics for a
week
in large part because they didn't do
anything for which they could be
criticized against the ravens they
fairly could be criticized for
abandoning a very effective run game
peter let's start there this run game
for the browns is for real forget about
all the money you've got invested noodle
beckham jr jarvis landry and austin
hooper when you can run the ball like
they did last night with nick chubb and
kareem hunt don't throw it if you don't
have to
well that's that's right mike i looked
down at the end of the night and i said
man this t have they rushed for 250
yards and it wasn't quite that but it
was 215.
the one thing about this running game
that i think has a chance to be special
is that
most teams they have a one
and a one a
you know this team has a one and a one
you know and and it's like neither of
them is the backup the backup is the
2017 rushing champion
so to me
that will be the strength of this
running game
that they can both
at any given time be the key guy for
that running game and the really really
good thing
imagine when you're back up because i
think kareem hunt is one of the five six
eight best running backs catching the
ball out of the backfield in the nfl
and to me imagine he's your backup
so so that is going to be the strength
of this team
you know they they have a good chance to
get through the season with both of
these guys you know being able to to do
it
for a long time and to be able to stay
healthy because they're not killing one
of them
and it's amazing they both had over 100
yards from scrimmage chubb with 124
rushing hunt with 86
rushing and another 15 receive and give
him 101 for the game and they each had
two touchdowns i mean when we showed put
that graphic up again when you see the
stats
you that would you would just assume
either guy was the lead tailback for his
team that week
not both did it in the same game and
again it takes away from the number of
opportunities that your receivers and
tight ends will have but when it's
effective how can you argue against it
this is the formula because
we said this yesterday far fewer things
are going to go wrong for you if you're
running the ball effectively than if
you're trying to spray the ball all over
the place in the passing game peter
well the amazing thing is the other
thing i looked at last night after the
game is that
you know look
chubb had 36 snaps last night kareem
hunt only had 20 snaps in this game
so there is so much more to do if they
want now again mike
i know what you're alluding to right
here
and you are alluding to hey look this
should be a running team and i get it
you're absolutely right
but
is the ego of odell beckham jr going to
allow them
to basically be that kind of running
game you know
everybody would say hey listen
let's control the clock we can be great
if we could put 35 points up
you know and and and run it this often
let's try to do that if we can every
week it kills the clock everything but
you know there are other factors at play
in cleveland and again look i'm not
trying to pick on beckham i'm really not
i'm just stating a fact
but if he's not getting a lot of
opportunities he's probably going to be
a squeaky wheel
and kevin stefanski i got to give him
credit when you're talking about playing
your first game on sunday and turning
around on thursday night there isn't a
lot of time to learn lessons to reflect
on what went wrong week one and what
needs to go right week two but they made
a greater commitment to the running game
they weren't forcing the passing game
against the ravens and part of this is
it's the ravens the passing game
was just horrible and they'd run the
ball and it worked but they kept getting
away from the run this time it felt more
like they were using the first half
to pass the ball set the rhythm and then
flip to the run once you've placated odo
beckham jr with his touchdown with a few
other catches now we can run the ball
now we have a lead and now we can just
spend the second half grounding and
pounding maybe that's the winning
formula for the browns although the
reality is it's whatever
each given game requires last night what
was required and what was effective was
starting with the pass building that
double not yeah they had a double-digit
lead fairly early 14-3 and then just
settling into a highly effective running
game that the bengals couldn't stop
yeah and i think you have to look at
it's like bill belichick says i don't
know if he ever said this but this is
this is the way it is with him you know
every game plan is different every game
plans a snowflake and you shouldn't look
you shouldn't just say hey listen we're
going to run it 55 percent of the time
this year that's what we're going to do
how do you know what you're going to do
until you get in the game you can't you
can't make a prediction like that you
may want to run it
more than you throw it but a lot of
times you're not going to have that
choice just like the bengals last night
they get behind big early they're not
able to run the ball consistently well
so joe burrow throws it 61 times the
other thing that was so weird about that
game i mean the bengals had 92 offensive
plays
and and again i i i look everybody
was impressed with joe burrow you know
in his first five days as an nfl player
who doesn't think that this guy is the
answer for cincinnati he is
and you know the other thing i like
about joe burrow
you know i know we're going to get into
them is that
he's got a little stuff to him mike
and he's got this he's got this attitude
that i do not care what you think about
me
and
and and and i think that was on display
last night
and you know lebron tweeting about him
in mid game
and all that i i just i was really
impressed with burro and uh you know i
was i i was impressed with the browns
too
because the browns were multi-faceted on
on offense and entering that game you
have to admit we all had questions about
whether they could be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports